good afternoon everyone my name is
Elizabeth Espinoza I executive director
of communications for the Los Angeles
County Sheriff's Department we thank you
so much for being here with us today in
the order of speakers that we will have
today will be LA County Fire Chief Daryl
Osby and then we will have LA County
Sheriff Alex bien welcome to the podium
thank you
let's go live good afternoon my name is
Daryl Ostby and I'm the fire chief of
the Los Angeles County Fire Department I
want to thank you for coming here to
today's briefing of the willow incident
today shortly before 10 o'clock at 9:47
a.m. the last Lewis County Fire
Department received a 911 call of a
potential helicopter down and a brush
fire at the intersection of Las Virgenes
Road and Willow Glen Street in the city
Calabasas and unincorporated Los Angeles
County upon arrival our firefighters
discovered approximately a quarter acre
of brush fire that resulted from a crash
on the hill on the hillside the
lawfulness County Fire Department
initial response was 15 pieces of
apparatus and 56 personnel that
consisted of paramedics Engine Company
heavy rescue truck company hand crews
and aircraft and the chief officer to
oversee the incident upon arrival during
the incident and upon arrival of the
Sheriff's Department
our to the respective departments
entered in a unified command to handle
this incident our firefighters on scene
indicated that there was a debris field
and steep terrain with a quarter acre of
brush fire that was occurring at the
time our firefighters hiked in to the
accident site with their medical
equipment and hose lines to extinguish
the stubborn fire as it included the
brush fire debris from a helicopter and
the fire also included magnesium which
is very hard for our firefighters to
extinguish because magnesium reacts with
oxygen and water in addition to our
firefighters hiking into the incident we
had one helicopter flying to the
incident with firefighter paramedics
onboard those paramedics were hoisted
down to the
incident early into the incident they
did a search of the area for survivors
unfortunately all the survivors on board
were determined to have been perished
firefighters and hand crews work to
extinguish the fire while carefully
prefers preserving the incident for
investigation
I'm currently this investigations to
ongoing I would like to turn this over
to my sheriff to continue the press
briefing
Thank You chief Osby personnel from lost
he'll share estates and responded to the
scene of the crash site
and assisted the fire department and
we've established a containment area and
now our Aero Bureau has a handle on
traffic or aircraft accidents however
when there's a fatality then it switches
to the National Transportation Safety
Bureau the NTSB and the Federal Aviation
Administration the FAA FAA is already on
scene and assisting we're waiting the
arrival of the coroner's office to
assist in the recovery of the remains as
the chief indicated there were no
survivors we have a manifest that
indicates that there was nine people on
board the aircraft the pilot plus eight
individuals there's wide speculation is
who the identities are however it is
being entirely inappropriate right now
to identify anyone by name until the
coroner has made the identification
through their very deliberative profits
and they've made made notification so
next of kin and it be extremely
disrespectful to understand that your
loved one of those perished and you
learn about it from TMZ that is just
wholly inappropriate so we're not going
to be going there we're gonna wait to
the coroner does their job and we're
assisting the families of those who
believe there have been impacted and
it's a it's a it's a tough process and
our hope goes out to all of the members
they were on board all the family of
everyone was on board this aircraft and
god bless their souls so at this point
in time we have nothing that we can add
until the coroner does their job and
we'll be making those notifications when
we have the information and we know the
next of kin have been notified then we
can release information publicly you'll
be notified in subsequent announcements
there's one
that is that is our belief yes thank you
so we realized at this point there are
so many questions there's a lot of
information out there and again we
understand you know we there's a lot of
information that's floating but we
certainly have a responsibility in an
obligation at a respective course for
the families and this is a very
difficult time for us all for the city
we have the mayor here of Calabasas also
City Council we think that for being
here and in fact they wanted to pass on
a message that for those in the
community that want to gather here and
are coming to Calabasas if you do you
are welcome to join others at the De
Anza park here in Calabasas and the
cross streets there are Lost Hills and
Las Virgenes
also the sheriff's Information Bureau we
will be sending out updates as to when
there will be if there is one a press
advisory out a notification of another
press conference or any other updates
through our Twitter so please look for
that and again we thank you so much for
being here today and again thank you
that the public can be able to get
anywhere nearby or as a stretch of Las
Virgenes can be shut down for an
indeterminate period of time remain shut
down